hiatus is coming and for chris sims
you're down to your last hour can you
manage to get through it are you are you
tingling with excitement like i cannot
wait to just check out for three weeks
and and not have to talk to you chris
how have you not yet seen the light that
patrick mahomes is the best quarterback
in the nfl and really what i came down
to as far as really the tiebreaker
between these guys because it's almost
like 1a and 1b to me is really just more
of the experience factor at this point
is where i kind of give aaron rodgers
the advantage there hello aaron rodgers
i love you so much we could have been
buddies if you've been paying attention
you know there's only one left and he
plays for the packers and it's not
desean kaiser it's aaron rodgers number
one on the chris sims top 40 quarterback
countdown are you gonna send him like
some sort of a plaque or a trophy or
something one of those one of those fish
that you press the button and it sings
anything like that no i should i should
do something like that from him more is
on his shoulders up in green bay than
any quarterback in football as far as
just carrying the team that way and last
year was it the best year of his career
no it certainly was not and i'm not
totally giving him the free pass there
too there was moments where i know he
could have played better but ultimately
they failed him a lot more than he
failed them i mean that's what i'm i'm
sure about the camera don't lie baby uh
and uh so you know you're looking good
man i don't know we're on the makeup
yeah
good to go
the the toupee's holding up pretty well
hey screw you i'll see you in four weeks
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports